Hello,
freak bitches.
Can You keep it real?
Can You keep it?
100.
Look at that lady.
What is she doing?
Is She doing the Dab?
Dab It on him.
Are you sure?
She's dabbled.
She just doing Tai Chi in the park.
Deafness says it on her shirt on a shirt that she doesn't know she's wearing.
She didn't realize that she can't read the blind.
No one,
hundred and 50,000 years old lawyers keep pounding.
Have we think it's so funny when old people talk as if they were ever young and
fucking like as if they've never had sex.
Like that lady probably at one point in time was a Dick connoisseur.
He's out there in the park not knowing what the fuck she's wearing.
The addict connoisseur in the park.
That's probably the best place probably to be sampling Dick.
Probably hard to get a good one though when you're at that age is probably real
tough because it's all about enthusiasm.
Like dudes are pretty down with old ladies.
Like old dudes.
You.
Oh yeah.
Well that's an issue.
I'm a friend of mine.
Go on.
One of his buddies worked at a old folks home and said that one of the big
issues was these old guys would get Viagra and these old ladies,
they didn't give a fuck and a lot of them are on antidepressants,
so they're like la La la who gives a shit like they're on Xanax and getting stds
will.
I don't know if it was that.
That's something that I heard about,
like it's rampant because that's happening.
Well,
that's probably really bad when you're old,
right?
Like your body doesn't heal so good.
No list when you're fucking 98.
Well,
herpes is like an attack on your immune system.
There it goes.
The new erotic frontier,
sex in nursing homes.
Until recently,
nursing homes frowned on sex.
Now increasingly they smile.
Oh,
it didn't make sense.
Why?
Why shouldn't we have fun?
Look at this.
When Aubrey Davidson age 85 minutes,
special guy at the Hebrew home in Riverdale in the Bronx,
New York,
they did more than sit next to each other in the dining room.
Then he invited her to his room.
They hung a do not disturb sign on the door and at breakfast the next morning,
they both sported broad smiles,
terrible writing like a fourth grade,
but also calling it.
What are the top say that you see the new erotic frontier.
You're like,
Ooh,
and it's like sex and nursing homes.
You're like,
oh,
there goes the boner.
Well,
it sounded so hot.
Yeah,
that's not.
It's not exciting for me,
but there's a whole category on youporn that so old people do.
Some people do like watching old people.
Fuck,
you know,
when I watched the other day,
I'm not proud of it,
but I will admit it to you.
I watched an old thing,
my special.
I watched an old porn stars still at it.
I don't care what he provides.
Exercise or this topic,
and at the time of life,
when many elderly feel cold sleeping as a payer provides warmth.
Oh,
that's cute.
Look at this though.
Killed back to that.
Relationships make people happier and that happiness reduces stress and
irritability and improves mood,
appetite,
sleep,
sociability and immune function.
Plants.
Read that first.
Oh,
how dare you read the first sentence says the Hebrew home,
that first one at the bottom of the Hebrew home does more than tolerate resident
nookie.
The faculty hope probably someone who works at the Hebrew home propaganda that
faculty holds regular happy hours,
dances,
and even organized a dating service for residents.
Gy Date,
g four grandparents.
I like it.
I didn't mean to force you into bringing up that subject.
Well,
the other problem with the second season of fear factor,
and I can say this now because it didn't happen as I was worried we were going
to kill somebody.
I was really worried.
It seemed too dangerous.
They were ramping up the stents and they were making things like way more
spectacular and you're,
you're just taking bigger chances and there was a lot of downtime in between.
There was a lot of preparation.
There was a lot of like checks and balances and they really wanted to make sure
that everything was tested and tested and they really mapped it out well,
but it was still.
There were some hair raising things he's fucking people had to do.
Maybe fear was too far,
maybe it should've been like mildly uncomfortable factor where you put people
like an mildly uncomfortable situations.
Like,
Hey,
I want you to go over and talk to that woman.
She seems kind of attractive.
What I mean.
So it's kind of a mildly uncomfortable and you.
No one's going to die.
No one's going to mind if she kills you there.
Um,
they're doing a new one with ludicrous.
It's Kinda that way.
There's a new fear factor and ludicrous.
The rapper is the host and like some of the fears like forgetting your cell
phone somewhere like for like,
right,
isn't it?
Something stupid like that.
And they don't have to eat anything gross.
Which was,
it was really dumped and keep that out because that was one of the most popular
parts of the original series that was gigantic.
Like the eating gross shit part as huge.
I have to be honest with you.
That was,
I couldn't watch that.
That was the hard part for me.
I don't,
I hear you,
you know,
it was hard for me to watch somebody do something because I wouldn't eat it or
drink it.
Then I don't want to watch somebody else do that,
but that's.
I'm with you.
I mean,
I wouldn't have won.
Well,
that's not true.
I watched somebody sent me a clip of Steve Hoe with a gas mask on and I tweeted
it,
some guy farting into a tube and it goes right into Steve [inaudible] face and
he threw up into the mask and I laughed so hard that I retweeted it
and send it to me.
It was actually quite rude of him,
but it was in response to allies of slessinger his appearance yesterday,
the podcast.
Look at this.
Look,
this guy's got a fart into this tube and the tube goes right into Steve
[inaudible] face like this.
He farts and Steve,
I liked it.
I almost threw up right there.
I almost threw up.
I'd like to bring like a
revived from the dead,
like Edgar Allen Poe or Mark Twain and put them in a time machine and bring them
to now and go,
all the stuff you did was like really cool.
Check out.
What we're doing now is show them that video.
Well video back then if I had a cell phone camera that he might've given up on
poetry,
like fuck all this rave and stuff.
Nobody's buying these deep black bird poems.
Does anybody have like a gas mask?
He had a fat guy to part two.
Let's make some real entertainment.
And the radio program director came into my town knew and you know if you've
ever been in radio,
when they come into town,
knew the first thing they're going to do is change everything because they got
to put their own stamp on it or why are they there?
So this guy comes in and he goes,
we're gonna rebrand you.
He goes,
I want everyone to think of your name and instantly think of the brand and I'm
already,
you know,
brand.
Yeah.
Okay.
So here's what he said.
So I hate to say this because this will become a meme online that I will have to
live with the rest of it,
but it's an absolutely true story.
So the guy says to me,
he goes,
listen to imagine a billboard that says Dan Carlin,
he fucks chickens.
And I said,
excuse me?
He goes,
yeah,
I mean,
so that anytime anybody thought they would think,
okay,
he's the chicken fucker and I'm going,
wait a minute.
Really?
He really said that.
And I said to him,
I said,
I said two things dude.
the first thing is I got to live in this town,
right?
So really you want that to be the first thing people think.
Okay.
The second thing is I got to have a career after this stupid idea of yours
fails,
right?
Like,
no,
you don't understand where we're building up a mental image,
you will be a household name.
I said,
yes,
I'll be the household name.
The guy who fucks chickens
and finding no,
he was.
After that I finally.
I said,
dude,
do you want to step outside right now?
My wife laughed at me because I'm already an old man when I'm saying she goes,
that would have been great.
I said,
no,
this,
this guy was as old as I was,
but I was so incensed and so angry that this guy would be so cavalier with your
future and as a human being in every family.
I mean,
my kids,
how are they going to spell fucker on billboards?
You know what?
Pets have really good credit they might have had as a euphemism,
but I mean,
you think about that.
You think,
okay,
as you said,
this guy's career depends on him making a difference.
I'm just a tool in his career.
Right?
So you start to realize that when you did the podcast and it's your podcast,
the person that you're worried about here is you and not just that,
the ideas that are coming from your.
Not just yours alone,
but you own them.
Right?
So,
so when I say something that's stupid,
I own that.
It's not like some stations said,
oh listen,
push.
You know,
I got into a fight over the Oj Simpson thing when the Oj Simpson trial is going
on and everybody,
it's all you hear anywhere,
so I didn't talk about it and so they got on me about not talking about it.
I had a big fight and I walked into the studio and I said,
fine,
I'll talk about it.
I said,
you know,
the whole topic was,
isn't there just too much?
Damn Oj Simpson everywhere you go.
Oh,
they were,
they were at the,
you know,
there was a window.
We were like zoo creatures and I had this window,
they could bring all the sales clients to watch us perform and I'm doing there
and there's like five executives in the window just waiting till the next
commercial break because we're going to be what I mean,
that's why radio is so awful for me and I didn't get fired.
I must've done a good enough job to stay employed,
but it was go home and pull your hair out.